командир сандрі кротевич телефонує її
брат перший заступник командира полку
Азов Богдан крутевич чоловік повернувся
в Україну 21 вересня під час найбільшого
обміну військовополоненими від початку
повномасштабного вторгнення РФ понад три
місяці він перебував у полоні у Москві
щойно повернувшись крутевич одразу
долучився до справ якими опікувалася
його сестра і вже почав займатися
планами щодо повернення решти
українських бійців Ми себе Наприклад
наша асоціація лише себе підсилила цим
обміном і поверненням керівників тому що
саме Керівники це їх бійці вони за них
будуть боротися так як не буде боротися
ніхто і вони вже це роблять вони не
відпочивають вони не лікуються вони вже
входять в роботу і займаються цим
причини такого поспіху в полоні досі
перебувають сотні захисників Маріуполя і
їх стан враховуючи нелюдські умови
утримання з кожним днем погіршується
мені дуже не сподобалось заголовки що
всі Захисники Азов сталі повернулися
Вибачте людей було дуже багато Майже
2000 людей і ви кажете що повернулося
лише 200 чоловік і кажете про всі
Захисники Азов сталі Так це дуже велика
подія це дуже щаслива подія особливо для
нас для кого у кого вже повернулася
хлопця але ну має бути якась повага до
інших сімей коли вся країна стежила за
поверненням захисників азовсталі Євген
цугарніков щосекунди зупиняв онлайн
трансляцію аби роздивитися кожен кадр за
кілька годин чоловік зрозумів що новини
для його родини будуть невтішними десь
близько 2-ї години ночі ми звичайно з
дружиною матеріали дивились чекали
сподівались з'явився вже офіційний
список близько
години і ми побачили що там нема
прізвища і відповідно зрозуміло що в цей
транш не потрапили на дитину після
теректу волинівці сухарніков знайшов
відео де на одну мить промайнув його син
за словами Євгена боєць був більше
схожим на тінь ніж на людину настільки
він схуд після останнього обміну з
Євгеном зв'язалися побратими сина які
вже повернулися в Україну військові
підтвердили батькові жахливі умови
утримання Він живий і
сказали що їх годують жахливо але
годують там
один хлопець з такого фразу скажеш
почали краще годувати
почали краще годувати стали давати
більше хліба трішки Тобто Ну от по цьому
навіть по цій зміні меню можна зрозуміти
наскільки
в них там умови
ну принаймні вони не помирають з голоду
це для мене вже як для батька хорошого
новина після почутих розповідейців які
повернулися мама іншого азовця в полоні
Тетяна ще більше переживає за свого сина
зокрема про його стан після ймовірного
катування голодом у нас при житті
нормальному 62 був той час 30 тому що
одною мамою
син 105 був час 57 ну
голодомор як голодомор люди кістки шкіра
Тетяна не знає де перебуває її син Вона
не мала жодної звістки про нього з
моменту його виходу за зростання жінка
вірить що її син живий І що він
повернеться додому однак непокоїться що
і без того погані умови утримання взимку
стануть нестерпними
хай тільки трошки швидше роблять
зима йди холодно опалення 100% там нема
[музика]
блохи на думку рідних документувати І
надавати розголос нестерпним умовам
перебування бранців мали би міжнародні
організації зокрема Червоний Хрест цю
думку поділяє і дружина азовця в полоні
Арсенія федусюка Юлія жінка регулярно
спілкується з представниками інших
держав і міжнародних організацій останні
на її думку показують низьку
ефективність Я розумію що росіяни їх не
пускають То вони не підуть штурмувати цю
оленівку але я проблеми з списками
Червоний Хрест взагалі його завданням
єдиним по суті яке вони визнають було
записати всіх військовополонених зробити
список цього немає зокрема коли
Захисники азовсталі виходили у полон
Юлії повідомили що її чоловіка серед
бійців немає це виявилось неправдою
однак тепер на федосюк час наголошувати
на поверненні всіх бійців додому а не на
покращенні їхніх умов за сприяння
Червоного Хреста дуже сподіваємося що це
відбудеться що їх туди допустять але на
такому фундаментальному рівні звісно тут
питання обміну важливіше тобто щоб
просто їх витягати звідси тому що про
умови про допуск ми говорили три місяці
вже в Годі про це говорити Вже треба їх
всіх обмінювати Євген сухарніков взагалі
побоюється що нещодавні повернення 215
захисників Маріуполя зокрема
командування приглушить хвилю підтримки
українських полонених на думку чоловіка
повернення бійців це перемога однак
зупинятися в жодному разі не можна влада
в першу чергу має розуміти що ті
обіцянки Я десь там в Фейсбуці побачив
щось Зеленський молодець обіцяв виконав
насправді ні тобто Дякуємо виконав
частково але
це лише там не знаю може 10% від того що
справді треба зробити за даними
віце-прем'єрк Ірини варищук Росія
отримує У полоні ще дві з половиною
тисячі українців правозахисники
називають більші цифри зокрема 7-8 тисяч
осіб серед полонених за даними полку
Азов близько 800 азовців натомість
України утримає значно більше російських
військовополонених однак і в глядачів і
в родичів українських бійців складається
враження що для росіян їхні рядові
солдати не мають великого значення а
отже на наступні обмін на вірогідно
більше впливатимуть політичні
домовленості аніж бажання Кремля не
кинути своїх
[музика]